hey guys it's max from axe sect today we
are getting our first hands-on
impression with the Google pixel for of
course this phone has been leaked like
crazy Google announced it already I
think this is the case but we just got
it in thanks to Google part of the pixel
program so thank you guys for sending
that out of course we're gonna be doing
our standard comparisons we're gonna
have a great photo comparison maybe some
astrophotography stuff so you guys
definitely don't want to miss out on
those but for now we can only do
hands-on unboxing impressions so let's
do it now I didn't know which color
we're gonna get so it looks like we got
the white one I think let's pull this
out and I'll just give you guys kind of
an impression using this phone and how
it feels like in the hand all those kind
of things that you can't really get from
the spec sheet because obviously you
guys already know all of the specs so
first impressions it feels kind of slim
but I don't know let's see let's get
this one out my this is my 11 Pro max
and yeah you guys might be able to tell
that the pixel 4 is slightly slimmer on
the sides then my 11 Pro max now the
other thing that I'm noticing is that
this little plastic little insert
between the glass and the display it's
not as smooth as it is on iPhone I
thought it's almost seamless you don't
notice it here it sticks out kind of
like I had iPhone 6 where I put in an
aftermarket display and it didn't sit
flush so that's instantly noticeable
it's also slightly taller than my 11 Pro
max that's interesting not by much but
you do notice it now on the back the
finish is much smoother so even though
this is a matte finish it is almost like
it's glossy just slightly matte compared
to this thing it's a very I don't know
how to describe a sandy feeling it feels
a lot more like satin compared to the
matte glass back of the iPhone now
another interesting thing that I wasn't
expecting is how grippy these sides are
so we have this matte black frame
aluminum frame but I expect it to be
very slippery like the iPhone ones but
it's almost like it has a little bit of
a texture and it feels quite nice I
would have to say that this phone feels
nicer in the hand
more confidence holding it compared to
holding my iPhone 11 Pro max now I have
this set up here for face unlock and a
lot of things that Google is doing here
just reminds me of what Apple is doing I
don't know if I'm allowed to say that
but it is what it is so I absolutely
love face unlock Hey it's actually
telling me where to go
all right well this is more difficult
than on the iPhone hold the phone steady
rotate your head
go slow okay oh there we go I guess it
was working that's it not a second time
like the iPhones do interesting all
right let's continue of course we have
the navigation that is similar to the
iPhone now with the latest version of
Android which I do like so we have the
face unlock just like on the iPhones I
love that we have the navigation swipe
up go side to side I love that let's
flip it around and take a look at our
cameras over here so as you guys can
tell this looks very similar to the
renders of the iPhone before they did
the all glass back I think the fact that
they added the dark frame the black
frame on the sides makes this complete
back camera array look much better than
if they would have had this and had like
a silver edge or a white edge or color
matched it but I don't think it looks as
nice as something like that now we do
have the little power button that is a
little offset on the color I'm not a big
fan of that but it is what it is let's
test out the new radar feature and one
thing that's really cool I think
probably the coolest thing is when you
reach out for the phone you actually see
that little lock icon that pops up so it
knows that you're going for your phone
so Prime's the whole array of sensors
that are hidden right up here inside
this forehead that way as soon as you
pick up your phone BAM it doesn't locks
that is that is really quick so not only
do we have as you guys can see this
always-on display
it actually unlocks for you
automatically and I really like that of
course with the iPhone we do not have
all of our little notifications at the
top of this little bar you have to see
it at the home screen or the lock screen
unless it's hidden away so with the
iPhone they have to have force you to
you know turn on the phone and then
swipe up to get in there whereas with
this you have the advantage of just
speed bam you're right there and you can
start doing whatever you want to do now
just like with the face unlock that I
love with other device we also have our
new gesture based navigation now this is
something I complained about with the
pixel 3 with the new software they added
this and I love being able to go back
quickly much quicker and much more
efficient and a swipe up to get to your
home screen now one thing I'm really
curious about is the sound quality we no
longer have those dual front firing
speakers we still have a stereo setup
but let's go ahead and see how good it
sounds because I was always a strong
suit of the pixel
[Music]
interesting very interesting so I hear a
lot of separation inside of it sounding
like the sound is coming from the phone
I feel like I hear the right channel
separate from the left channel it's not
blending in definitely isn't super loud
but first impressions not bad the
clarity is definitely there
now Google sent us the Excel version and
this thing has a really high res display
and they really were talking about how
great the display is the contrast ratio
though is not as high as some others and
I maxed out the brightness right now and
it's not blindingly bright now it may
get brighter in auto brightness modes
we'll have to check that later for our
full review but here it's pretty good
when we max it out and now let's go
ahead and open up a YouTube video and
man I really like the the little
navigation at the bottom works so well
and this is and it's an 8k HDR video of
course we can't playback an 8k but
thankfully we can playback in 1440p 60
with HDR and so that actually matches
the panel and here I mean the image
looks really good
Wow really good colors the HDR is
looking good and as far as detail and
sharpness and brightness watching this
HDR video it looks quite good now
something I'm noticing is that the
little the way that display is rounded
it is quite substantial here in the
corners it kind of stands out a little
bit and especially having that forehead
be offset with the chin that gives it a
little bit of a weird look compared to a
lot of other phones but the quality
looks nice now one interesting thing is
the choice of having a telephoto instead
of an ultra wide I personally use the
telephoto more although I think it is
more important to have an ultra wide of
course we have a lot of other things to
take a look at one thing I'm very
curious about is the battery life
because we have this 90 Hertz display
which is part of the reason why I just
felt so fluid while I was testing this
and these new gestures we'll see how
that will be affecting the 3800 milliamp
hour battery we do have a decent charger
18y USB type-c that looks surprisingly
familiar
here so that's something we're going to
be testing out of course we're going to
do ass wide variety of comparisons
looking at all the different aspects and
some detailed photo comparisons that you
guys have seen in the past so make sure
you guys are subscribed if you guys have
any questions ask in the comment section
below we'll try to adjust those in our
full review that we're going to be
working on thank you guys for watching
that has been max and I will see you in
the next video
[Music]